now I'm just gonna give you a personal
story back from when I was here Nam in
school nothing felt more I mean honestly
I don't know why I think there are other
things maybe mechanics but nothing felt
more like oh you're an extension to
student that integration by parts just
to say oh yeah you just do it by posit
like what does that even mean right
sounds like some magic incantation what
this is about and I did allude to it
before is that we have seen chain rule
for differentiation and then we saw
reverse chain rule for integration and
we understand that we've been using it a
lot every time you do integration by
substitution you're using reverse chain
rule but then we saw I can't rule for
differentiation there's the product rule
what's kind of the comparison in
integration and it's kind of integration
by parts integration by parts is kind of
the reverse product rule it is a reason
why it's not called the reverse product
rule and when we have a look at I think
I've got one two three examples um once
we have a look at some examples you'll
see why there are at least two good
reasons why it's not called the reverse
product rule but first we need to know
what on earth this thing is okay so it
does begin with the regular product now
if I said to you
if I said to you I have a arm I have a
function and what it's composed of is
the product of two other functions okay
we know the product rule inside out by
now most of us will find it in this way
at least that's the way I say it and
that's the way I think it if you've got
some sort of comparison I'm sure it's
not that far
okay now two things I want to do here
firstly over here on the left hand side
I've written U of X and V of X to remind
you that U and V are actually functions
they're not just you know you variables
with different things and on the right
hand side I've written it in this form
because that is the most concise form to
write it and because in the context of
using this pretty much we're always
differentiating with respect to a single
variable so you no need to worry about
which what it is okay but that's about
to change
so I'm gonna do two things number one
I'm gonna write the left-hand side as
just you and me because you know you've
got it you might get these are functions
on the right-hand side I'm gonna write
you - and V - in proper drdx for right
so other right this has V times D u1 DX
that's what you - actually means plus u
times DV this is nothing good now this
is differentiation what I want to get is
something to do with integration so as
you've seen before we're going to take
this whole thing and I'm going to
integrate everything and with respect to
X okay now I am gonna do this as an
indefinite integral but for the sake of
convenience I'm just going to leave off
the fact that there is a constant of
integration and once we state the rule
you remember oh yeah there's a constant
integration somewhere okay so if I
integrate this thing with respect to X
what does it become
it just returns back to what one and
again unless you there is kind of a
constant integration flying around but
I'm about to have a pair of integrals
here which will also have constants of
integration in there
so I'm looking with some weights
baked-in now when I integrate each of
these with respect to X I would have
integral DX integral DX you agree with
that but just as we seen a hundred times
with integration by substitution that DX
is that I add on are going to cancel
with these / D answers that are already
there
does that make sense so what this line
becomes is the integral of V du u + the
integral of U DV okay so now we're
almost there I've turned a
differentiation statement into an
integration of statement I will do one
more thing I am going to make you DV the
integral of U DV I should say I'm going
to make it the subject so what is this
going to be able to well all I need to
do is subtract that guy from both sides
do you agree so what I actually have
would it be this did you see it take
that for the big box around it this is
the definition of integration by parts
now what is this what is it even mean
okay the idea is over here if you have
some integral and it is a product of one
function and another and the functions
that are naming them U and DV DX if you
can define them as such and work out
what all pieces are over on the right
hand side these are the parts where
integration by parts gets its name then
you can take that integral you can
evaluate